it was my first experience it was like
falling in love for the first time I
really learned everything through the
show I'm Liz Parker and five days ago I
died after that things got really weird
when you first heard that they were
remaking Roswell what was your initial
reaction I mean when you first hear
they're doing it's almost a little
shocking like oh you know to the fact
like you like when they're doing charmed
or any of these bigger shows you're like
I understand then it's sort of
flattering oh you want to bring Roswell
back then you start to hear the take and
you're like this makes sense
they're definitely modernizing it every
small town has a story a my hometown
has a legend it's pretty wonderful to
come back and sort of be like wow 20
years later I'm directing I've really
grown a lot in this business definitely
feels as full-circle as something can be
to be giving Janene direction and saying
like my Liz would do this
how would your Liz ask mask sedan this
is lizard tech oh you know and she's
mexican-american and she is a provider
and a caretaker for her family and her
dad is undocumented these are also older
people you know we're not looking at
like high schoolers now we're looking at
people in there you know late 20s early
30s and life is much more complicated
life has been hard on them everything
I've ever done has been to protect
Isabel and you everything you've ever
done has been to protect yourself you
know her version of liz is ten years
older than my version of Liz so my
version was very naive and very
vulnerable and she's very much a strong
woman that knows what she wants who
happens to be in a similar situation
she's really created her own character
her own Liz I need answers so they start
off with a lot of the similar like story
beats Liz gets shot max saves her life
and then they're presented with this
otherworldly discovery this you know
absolute beacon of hope but then very
early on it becomes its own show and
shows about other nests it's about
feeling alien and there are so many
versions of that I can show you what I
need to touch you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]